una visita sorpresa pero también muy
simbólica y que podría aumentar el tono
del enfrentamiento entre Rusia y
occidente es la que ha hecho hoy Joe
biden aquí a la capital ucraniana el
mandatario estadounidense se ha
desplazado hasta que en una jornada en
la que no han faltado de volver a oírse
las sirenas antiaéreas de hecho las
sirenas han sonado precisamente cuando
el mandatario de Estados Unidos se
encontraba caminando por las calles de
quiebre y en estas circunstancias vayan
a anunciado otro paquete de ayuda por
470 millones de euros en un momento en
el que los expertos dicen que Rusia se
está preparando para una guerra que aún
durará por mucho tiempo aún así la Casa
Blanca ha informado que comunicó al
remín del desplazamiento de la
mandatario estadounidense a Ucrania con
antelación para evitar mayores tensiones